et on va continuer à parler des états
unis avec notre invité douglas y être ce
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines bonjour
monsieur et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on vient de
le dire un tube hayden a remporté les
primaires en floride dans l'arizona et
dans l'illinois
l'ancien vice-président américain et
grand favori désormais pour
l'investiture démocrate
bernie sanders est il définitivement out
nobilis un bus va continuer à se battre
parce que vous savez pendant le mois
prochain
il n'y a pas beaucoup des délégués qui
sont en jeu donc dany 112 à toute
l'entrée de rester dans l'enjeu en plus
parce que vahid a promis de choisir une
femme comme ce truc a dit d'un colistier
lise présidente nos abris n'a besoin de
700 délégués de plus ça pourrit pas
arrivé jusqu'au mois de mai et entre
temps une accidents peuvent apprendre ou
par exemple maladie ou un gars aussi
tenable donc pour l'instant d'un nice
1-2 va continuer
alors justement l'ombre du coran et
vireux sans plana sur ces primaires
l'état de l'ohio a d'ailleurs décidé à
la dernière minute de reporter le
scrutin
quel impact l'épidémie pourrait avoir
justement sur ces primaires ouais il
semble jouer en faveur de baidu
c'était dieu la plupart de la campagne
de bernis inde et dans le porte-à-porte
et à cause de chati dame qui a paru de
plus en plus forte
le portrait reproduit plus possible donc
ça semble jouer en faveur de baidu mais
aussi eu des doutes si tous les
primaires vont se passer pour l'instant
le dirigeant du parti démocrate
le nageur aucune venture qui organise
les élections présidentielles a indiqué
qu'ils veulent continuer avec les
primaires mais avec une baisse de
participation alors du côté des
républicains
un seul candidat
trump qui est donc candidat à sa propre
réélection est ce que la gestion de la
crise sanitaire qui lie aux coraux n'ya
virus sera un élément clé lors des
présidentielles de novembre à votre avis
oui un double-top à marjorie se glisser
sur toi même avec son copain cité de la
vérité ils ont ils il y a les fêtes et
le vrai problème c'est moins que les
gens vont mourir c'est seulement un
problème mais que ça joue sur son
performances économiques
un des valeurs sûres dans la prédiction
d'élection présidentielle
c'est le résultat économique de deuxième
quartier de l'année et c'est exactement
ça qui c'est en juin avec cette pandémie
donc oui ça va plaisir sur les chances
de notre homme mais en plus je prends ce
train pas peur du job ied en à vous
toutes ces campagnes ukraine pour délit
jti n'est le cas ni d'arthur de joseph
byden et maintenant il se trouve de plus
en plus en face de son adversaire comme
il a mal pressentiment et s'ils perdent
le confiante et a aussi perdu dans
l'économie si paris n'arrive avoir le
charisme
ce sont deux clés comme et 13 clés qui
peuvent décider l'élection
présidentielle alors vous parliez de ce
bilan de donald trump on sait que la
présidente du parti républicain a twitté
hier que les militants étaient pleins
d'énergie prêt pour quatre ans de plus
de n'être pas ce qu'il fait vraiment
consensus 65 parties c'est juste de la
communication voilà peut-être une
communication pour essayer de cacher les
les craintes face à joe biden oui oui
celle c'est le com pure et simple
mais ils ont montré comment ça en effet
ses supporteurs dans l'apathie
républicaine ils gagnent sans même y
goûter toutes les voix des républicains
les républicains se soudent derrière les
qualités de 30 parce qu'il est le
candidat des républicains
donc il joue avec son 38 % soutiennent
ils jouent avec son parti mais en
réalité l'élection présidentielle jeu
avec le tir de lectra qui n'est ni
démocrates ni républicaine il trempe à
de gagner là bas et c'est passionnant
parce que lundi on dit maintenant
parmi les démocrates premier les
indépendante n'ait pas pas une
révolution dont bernie sanders princes
l'ambiance maintenant c'est pour une
retour nous maryse et qui est représenté
par les présidents au bras très bien en
tout cas merci beaucoup de glace haye
est un professeur de droit et
spécialiste en politique américaine
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
là c'est la fin